okay it is time for hatred mail hatred
mail is when a professional voice over
artist
interpretively reads the hate mail that
i get a quick reminder about
what hatred mail is now with a whole
slate of new coronavirus related hatred
mail introductions
last time i checked this was america and
i have the right to share my droplets
with whoever i want
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom that's a good one that's a
that's a very good one
uh okay let's get right in to this
week's hatred mail
why doesn't david marry joe biden if he
loves him so much
you are such a fearful little child
pac-man
dude's a corporate skill you have the
lamest political show on youtube
i don't even follow your show you just
proved
david pakman that you are relatively
ignorant
your angry caller jimmy is a hundred
percent right
and i have no idea why i'm still
subbed to this tripe this is a
playground
thing you know if you like biden so much
you should marry him because you're gay
right i mean it's
these hatreds have regressed or maybe
they never progressed past
sort of like being 10 years old it's
weird and unfortunately many of them are
i know this is crazy but they're in
positions of power uh
in this country come on guys we're
adults here okay biden is good on some
issues he's less good
on other issues he's orders of magnitude
better
than donald trump overall we shouldn't
deify
politicians we shouldn't idolize
politicians
and by the way nobody's forcing you to
subscribe to me
yes we are on the path to a million
youtube subscribers that's true
but you don't have to be one of them
hopefully we'll get over the finish line
by election day but
if you want to bow out by all means do
what's best for you i
am confident that there are uh very few
of these haters relative to the people
that are signing up and i think we'll
have some very very big things to
announce
from the standpoint of a million coming
to you very soon remember that you can
use the coupon code
hatred 40 to get 40 off the membership
of your choice at joinedpakman.com
the spelling very important all lower
case all one word
h a t r i o t 4
0.